when I first started trying to make
music I was very young and then by the
time I got the opportunity
I wasn't anymore as young as is
conventional to get through the door
there's this big kind of thing in the
press about my age when suddenly
everyone realized because somebody who
had a lot of time on their hands
it was God with my birth certificate and
presented it to Wikipedia I've no idea
who this person is could have just been
like anybody but went to the birth
difficult office found my birth
certificate which must have taken some
effort submitted it to wiki which meant
I was unable to change my date of birth
on their hear monthly which is what I've
been doing up till then and I was I've
been dying to have an opportunity to
discuss this very other woman because
the reason why I lied was partly because
of the fact that it taking me so long to
get there but partly because I feel like
there's a huge amount of pressure on
women in the media to be youthful
forever and there's a real patient with
our age like when you read an article
about a lot of male people they often
don't even quote the age
yeah with women even when I speak to
other women
you know you luckily haven't done it yet
but now other women I will agree with me
and then say but how old are you you
know I fit in what what I think about
the age thing of women is I've seen in
my own office is there's women are I
don't know more trained I think than men
to compare themselves all the time it's
it's a shame but I actually think it's
the whole thing that men are sort of
notoriously supposed to find the 20 some
think more attractive than they are the
thirty-seventh because apparently women
in their thirties are desperate to have
babies and women in their forties know
too much so
can't pull the wool over their eyes but
they think that's like the kind of
general unspoken consensus which I don't
necessarily agree with and also I just I
speak to a lot of men now and I the men
I'm close to think that women in their
thirties and forties are more sexy and
appealing and attractive because of
what's going on up there yeah but you
know the men I've gravitated to it with
the ones who but the reason why I
initially laughs they'd like the story
of it was because I remember when KT
Tunstall first came out and I read quite
a lot of articles print articles about
her and everyone said coming to music at
a very late age of what 31 she was 27
and I was just shocked and and then I
watched how that first album was hugely
successful and then it sort of fell off
a bit for her and I didn't see the
difference between like why I thought
there was just as many songs on the next
one as they were in the first book
because they'd emphasized so much her
age and it was drummed into us reading
all this literature is like it's a one
shot it's a one shot I just thought I
don't want that I'm gonna secure my
place and you know like if you secure
your place in this industry your age
doesn't matter because something like
Beyonce the same age as me yeah and
she's the biggest female artist in the
world yeah you know and who else
something I just thought someone could a
blondie made had a most success there be
having at 36 yeah and I was with her the
other day and I was like have to have a
picture with you you're my idol you're
an icon and you had your most biggest
success when you were older than I am
now so I was like really in fair